qu'est-ce que vous fait de moi dans la
vie en ce moment j'ai pas de nouvelles
depuis un mois si tu me regardes appelle
bonjour je m'appelle Thierry Ardisson
j'ai décidé de poser aux gens les
questions que je posais au snap
qu'est-ce que vous préférez chez vous ma
motivation
mes cheveux à l'heure où tout mes
camarades perdre les lames mon sourire
et qu'est-ce que vous haïssez chez vous
je sais pas mon manque de confiance en
moi manque de légitimité qu'est-ce que
vous préférez au cinéma
James blueway ce film avec Morgan
Freeman les évadés qu'est-ce que vous
détestez au cinéma j'en ai pas les films
que j'aime pas je vais pas au bout
qu'est-ce que vous préférez dans la
musique en ce moment j'adore les
vieilles rips je deviens nostalgique rap
US RnB et vieux sons
quel a été le plus grand moment de votre
vie en revenant dans le mal en ce moment
c'est pas mal j'ai toujours rêvé d'être
en face de gouttière quand j'ai su que
j'allais dans l'unité que je voulais et
le pire moment de votre vie une rupture
amoureuse
je pense qu'il y a rien de pire l'amour
de mon père parce que je le haïssais
qu'est-ce qui vous plaît le plus dans la
vie en général le fait qu'il y a un
lendemain
la vie tout qu'est-ce qui vous fait le
plus chier avant de faire mes devoirs
le manque de spontanéité les cons
qu'est-ce qui vous fait le plus rire
dans la vie les parodies que je vois sur
Instagram je sais pas si vous connaissez
les styles de vine tout ça j'aime bien
Haroun en ce moment pas mal
quand les gens se manquent des plus
faible l'insuffisance
quel a été votre plus belle histoire
d'amour
chaque fois c'est ma plus belle histoire
d'amour parce que je suis tellement con
que chaque fois je veux pique au truc
mais direct c'est drôle parce que la
première chose qui m'est venue à
l'esprit c'est ma grand-mère et votre
pire histoire d'amour celle-là aussi je
me suis barrée je suis la capitale lui
faire une déclaration d'amour il m'a dit
je sais pas quoi c'est chaud qu'est-ce
que vous avez de plus sexy en vous
Joker mais tatouages
[Musique]
une certaine tendance à prendre les
choses trop au sérieux parfois plein de
choses qu'est-ce que vous préférez dans
le sexe je te trouve non
le fait que ça se passe à deux le film
Rien dégoûte quand c'est pas consenti
donc toute votre vie votre plus belle
nuit
la plus belle de ma vie
[Musique]
une mauvaise biture au jean à 16 ans
qui veut pas me laisser dormir
en fait ou maman pendant toute la nuit
en fait
[Musique]
et pour être sûr de ne rien rater de
Inna larditube abonnez-vous et mettez un
pouce bleu